Diversity in the workplace
is the strategic representation of points of view
that leads to optimal decision making.
A few months ago,
we were doing a strategic planning for a very large
multinational company that sells napkins.
So I entered the room and there were 11 gentlemen
ready to start the strategic planning session.
And I said, is this us
or are we waiting for someone else?
And then they said, yes,
it's just us.
It's gonna be 12 gentlemen doing a strategic planning
for the number one sanitary napkin in the Philippines.
And I said, you're doing good,
but I think you can do greater.
If one of our teammates in this room even uses a napkin
or knows how painful it is to have dysmenorrhea
every month,
what is diversity?
Diversity is acknowledging that
even if we are doing so well,
we will acknowledge a perspective
that can even make us grander and better.
And sometimes you need interventions for that to happen.